today we will be working on end games
because this is the area of the game
that I think a lot of chess players
start your opening smidley game tactics
but somehow it gets a little bit neglect
at the end game so we're going to be
going over the many defined endgame
positions today and we're going to try
to understand how we play and game with
a kingdom pawn with the Bishop I will
also teach you how to checkmate with the
bishop and Knight with the bishops so
we'll do many different positions but
today lecture is going to be on end
games so we're going to start off with
the first position this may seem a bit
simple but I want to make sure even we
know all the simple positions first
before we move on to anything more at
the ends so the first position I have is
a king and pawn and game and here let's
say if it's white to play if it's white
to play in this position do you think I
can win this or it's a draw think about
it first it's white to play it's very
important that whose move is it in the
king the opponent games so if it's white
to play let's see
see
in this kind of end games you have to be
very precise if you make one mistake
when you're trying to win even you could
be winning but you make one mistake at
the end it will be a draw sir there are
a lot of places to go wrong but please
raise your hand if you know this
position okay we have few participants
okay that's good see that's why I want
to start off with this one even though
it's a very simple position you know but
you have to know how to play this so
what is the evaluation julian white is
winning this position okay
white is winning because you can make a
move here in that move is d 3 d 3 and
now you pass the turn and the fin the
kings are in front of each other like
this this is called opposition and when
you make a move now black needs to move
and whoever is going to move now he's
going to lose the opposition for example
if we had the same position it white to
move it's a draw because he loses the
opposition whichever side loses the
opposition that means he's not going to
be able to win or draw okay
so let's see how this works first we
will see how white wins and then we'll
see how black will draw this position if
it's white to move so he can go either
king c6 or e6 when he goes huge
now you go king to e5 in order to win
this endgame you have to get your king
in front first and then advance the pawn
okay if you push the pawn first and your
king is behind you're not going to be
able to win this so remember King needs
to get ahead okay so you go kinky 5 now
let's say he goes here many tricks here
many tricks you may think okay I got
opposition on winning but here again you
make one incorrect move such as d4 which
looks very natural right we pushed upon
guess what he plays here and now Kings
in front of each other what do we call
that opposition right and now he made
the move you have to move again he has
the opposition so remember
Kings in front of each other one squared
between them this is opposition okay and
which doesn't matter which side moves
white or black he's going to put them
into disadvantage so now so well
remember in order to win you have to get
your King ahead of the pawn if you push
this now your King cannot get ahead this
is a draw
so we'll see now what you need to do to
win so the best move in this position is
King to d5 to get the opposition again
now he has to move the King again he
goes away you go to the other side he
goes here what is the correct move King
D six get the opposition again now he
goes here now you have enough reserve
moves here with your pawn so at this
point you can start pushing okay this is
the most precise way to win you push he
gets in front of it he thinks okay I got
the opposition does he really have the
opposition no right because we can push
again we push we advance the pawn and
now we make a move he has to move again
and he loses the opposition he goes away
your King gets ahead push push and you
win again huh okay okay so you get a
queen now I want to go back to the same
position that we saw that is winning now
we're going to change this to black to
play okay to white to play here so now
you're going to be playing as black here
so now white needs to move that means he
loses the opposition right so now black
has the opposition so now let's see if
he moves here when you're trying to draw
you have to be very precise okay you
have to really make precise moves here
so let's say you have to play this move
anything else you play you lose
so you have to go King g6 because when
you play King g6 what do you do get the
opposition again right so now he goes
back again you get the opposition so now
he pushes keep the King in front of the
pawn he pushes and remember the best way
to defend this you go back in front of
the pawn
so he goes here you get the opposition
remember in order for him to win he
needs to get his King in front of the
pawn but he cannot do that because
you're blocking the square sea he cannot
get in front of the pawn so now he
pushes so here and now you have three
moves to play here only one move will
draw the other two losing straight
exactly
facing the palm right because now he
cannot come here to get the opposition
because his pawn is on that square so he
goes here now you play opposition
remember that our position now he goes
here go here okay still mate so that's
why there are many in games they end
with the stalemate if that's why the
stalemate is very important for many
different in games otherwise like
there's no moves so now so this the
opposition we saw how to win okay and
how to draw okay again if he moves you
get our position kings in front of each
other so it pushes you go in front of
the pond goes back you go back
King c7 yes Evan and now when you reach
this position this is the critical
position right here if you go wrong here
you will lose for example if you go to
EA Tour c8 you lose because now he goes
here and now White has the opposition
because black needs to move you move he
pushes you go away King to c7 neuquén
okay so that's why you play King D yes
yes okay so let's see now so this one is
let's just finish this one and now King
ge8 any tricks and now still mate again
okay so let's now change the position a
little bit and now you have a choice
here okay so let's say in this position
you have an extra square for the King so
you have this extra square here so now
you have four moves actually you can
play with black but three moves losing
so for example if you move the King here
it's losing because of king c6 right and
then he can just push so he goes away he
pushes and he Queens the punch so
remember you always when you're
defending you go in front of the pump
right this King back he goes here you
get the opposition okay alright now
let's look at the next position I have
for you next idea is let's see here this
endgame let's see if you can see if you
can win this one it's white to play and
win
we wrap up on and you should be able to
win any position in King and pawn
endgame when you have extra pawn most of
the time you're supposed to win and here
you can win but you have to know this
one idea well well the thing is if you
sacrifice your pawn you might not be a
twin because his King is going to be in
front of huh ah huh so let's think about
it first I don't want you to rush okay
so think about it if you go King c4
what's going to happen can you go King
g4 and then he starts pushing his D pawn
so let's think about it for a few
minutes and see if we can find the way
to win king c4 is a draw because of king
e4 so it's a seems like should be easy
but unless you know it you know what you
need to do you might have a hard time if
you'll notice so let's see
politics well if we push the pawn he
takes we take right but then see he goes
here and it takes the pawn but you want
to go here with the king
yeah but still he will just go here even
if I don't have my pawn it's a drop
because remember in order to win you
need to have your King in front of your
passport in a position like this blocked
it's already a draw okay let's yeah I
want you to Taylor planned oh yeah we
have of course pawn moves are losing
pawn pie I mean it's going to be a draw
so I need you to have a plan so think
about it what is the plum if you raise
your hand let's see what's the plan here
stay where I could get opposition with
this pawn if he ever goes after my back
on like what one can take off okay well
how can you get that though okay King d2
and now he goes here
all right
correct now what is black gonna do now
he can't go back because you simply come
to the train you in the pond
if he goes to g5 same thing yeah he goes
kindy three and you win the pawn again
and remember in this position when he
goes Kimi g5 he can't really take this
bike you can never take a pond like this
when opponent has to protected postponed
connected passed pawns like this you can
you can never take this one in the King
upon angry because the other one will
run okay because you cannot catch it if
you're running from behind you can I
catch it okay so that's why you can he
can never take this so you go King you
two very good and now he goes Kinki five
now
you could try King f3 King did three
back so now you reach the same position
I set up for you but now I black to move
and he doesn't have any good moves now
because if he goes back away from the
pawn we just take the pawn then you can
win now with a king and two pounds
easily and if he goes here to try to
protect the pawn now you push the pawn
he tries to catch it you don't rush to
take this because it's a draw now again
so you have to make sure you protect
okay now he goes here and now you're
winning because of two pawns let's see
how you win this position you probably
know how to do it but let's see you
improve the King and now you improve
your King again and push you advance one
pawn all the way to the seventh rank
remember and when he goes here you can
just push this one and always make sure
he has a square to go to okay so you are
still made him and as soon as he goes
here you step up he takes and you get a
queen okay
that's how you win this position who
knows what is this idea code that we
just did for white triangulation very
good because if you look see that's how
your King moves okay that idea called
triangulation you need to get to the
same position but his move and the only
way to do that you have to move your
King like a triangle to accomplish that
now I'm going to set up a position again
same idea but a little bit more
difficult on the same team okay okay
white to play and win using the same
triangulation idea whether so you need
to reach this exact position with black
to move because if it's black to move
he's going to go back huh okay okay
here and you go here raise it you raise
your hand so I can see I don't see you
in the back yeah so maybe move a little
bit this way yeah okay very good now I
can see you okay so if you're the King
moves back then we come in and then we
win the second part when you win the
second part you win but the question is
how we can get that point where we have
the let's see
spend some time okay Julian 10k it's not
very simple if you don't know it I
remember first time when I got this
position actually spent some time
because I I didn't know exactly this
idea so I had to spend some time and how
can we get that white wins here why to
move yes if it's black to move you will
win easily first move it's obvious we
can't step up with lose the pun so it's
obvious so he goes here the problem is
we cannot come up because in a previous
example we so right you get star
position and when you push he gets in
front of your phone end you cannot go
here because of still mate okay
draw so this will be a draw if you do
that so we cannot just go up and win
that would be too easy so what do we do
here to get the opposition remember
right what is triangulation I remember I
described I show you by arrows your King
moves like a triangle right okay yeah
just raise your hand if you have some
moves here huh King before that's fine
now again remember he cannot come up
because if he comes up what do we do
c5 we got the opposition so he's not
going to do he's going to go here now
continue
think we just came from d5e go see for
right now he goes here dink dink dink d5
now look at your king was here right so
you moved like this so it is a real nice
triangle here okay now he has few
options if he goes here then we go king
c5 and then you go here and win this
pawn a6 and if he goes to d8 opposition
again opposition now he has to go to c8
we push he goes here now don't promote
into a queen okay I've seen this happen
a lot
so you promote into a queen and you
realize it's still mate now what would
be the best most effective way to
checkmate I know we can promote into a
rogue but what would be the most
effective way to checkmate here three
moves perfect king c6 King a 8 then we
promote into a queen with check check
and mate okay so I want to go back and
do this one because it's a triangulation
but it's more difficult triangulation
okay so what is the first move okay we
know King D 5 is the first move and how
do we do the triangle to reach the same
position with his move ok yes go ahead
maybe you don't want to go to e4 no
don't go to e4 you can go c4 or if or so
we go to d4 remember he cannot come up
because you win because you get into
I'm going to go with that position too
but let's just see the triangulation so
now he goes here see how the King moves
and now a final move King d5 now he goes
here and you get the opposition and you
don't rush here when you're about to
promote the pawn make sure it's not a
still mate sometimes it could be a
stalemate so you just go here so now
let's see what's going to happen if you
place King c7 q c5 King c8 see without
this pause this would have been a draw
okay but with this pounce we can win
this position because we go king b6 now
he gets the opposition and without this
Posse with a bit of draw but now we can
take the pawn now how do you win this
remember you cannot afford to lose this
pawn okay we do lose this pawn it's
always a drawer the corner pawn king c8
yes King v6 which part we push in this
position to win which part we [ __ ] it's
a trickier can you promote the a pawn no
right it's a corner pawn it's the the
worst pun you can have an endgame unless
it's like a you know outside pass pawn
but with the you know position like this
you can really promote this one so you
always push the C pawn and you Quinn
checkmate and if it goes King c8 what do
you do push this pawn you use this pawn
as a waiting move you're not really
trying to I mean you can promote this
pawn to but if it goes here you can I
guess you can promote this pawn to and
have to Quincy if you want but you can
just go here okay okay do you do
everybody understand what is
triangulation means you really
understand okay great so because this
can happen actually in your games also
you know so you want to know what is
triangulation and how it works okay now
okay you are playing with the white
pieces and you need to make a decision
here to where to go with the king
huh yeah please erase your hand if you
can't because sometimes I don't know who
is saying so raise your hand so I can
see that it's you or maybe somebody else
okay
so it's white to play and win but if you
make the wrong move now you might not be
able to win or you may make the task
very difficult maybe not even gonna be
able to win actually so you really need
to know here where what where to go and
what's the plan to win this position in
end games you always want to have a plan
yeah yes ensure it's White's move right
yes any particular reason why you would
choose b8 / d8 well if he doesn't block
with this with his vision that you can
put your vision on f3 to control the
forward progress or the bottom to
control what sorry the forward progress
on the farm
well the pawn is going this way oh the
other way yeah you're white so you're
going you know you you're trying to
promote this pawn but I'm guarding this
square so if you promote it I will
gladly just take that pawn with my
bishop and it will be a draw right you
can't checkmate me with one bishop so
your goal is not to promote opponent
help me take in with the bishop that's a
draw your goal is somehow to promote it
to a full queen okay try to you know in
chess discipline is very important yeah
so just you know yes
I wouldn't worry about King b7 but if
you go King d8 well King b7 I think
loses to Bishop p8 and here see that's
what I'm trying to time trying to block
that diagonal and Quinn so it's it's a
you have to notice that's why I want to
set up this position for it's a very
instructive idea I think here to know
because if you just look at it you might
not realize what you really need to do
in order to win this game who can tell
me what you need to do first step first
step what you need to do well excellent
that is excellent you need to move his
Bishop from this diagonal okay the only
way we can move him if you put the your
bishop on that diagonal okay okay and
this is a long diagonal here okay long
diagonal means many squares the bishop
can go to see all the squares he can go
to if it needs to okay so you need to
move this bishop from a long diagonal
and who can tell you which one is a
short diagonal for the bishop to protect
upon a short diagonal that has only few
squares to go to yes yeah this is very
easy a68 very important now we know that
now we know that perfect so now how we
find how do we make a plan to move this
bishop from here okay yes but where
be eight correct now let's say place
King be six okay
now he's going to make a waiting move
because he's hoping you promote this so
you can take now how we get this bishop
away from the long diagonal that's step
number one for us
yes huh okay how well I mean how where
should we bring this bishop huh if we go
here it doesn't really do much because
he's not going to take he's on a long
diagonal remember he has many squares
too good he will just reject that
sacrifice yeah but keep coin is he's got
large very good you want to come see see
the front maybe come here yeah and raise
your voice your name and okay just raise
your hand yeah and think you don't trash
I think okay very good
okay so we go here right very good
we are on the right track now he goes
here Bishop to c8 right okay Bishop c8
he cannot exchange because it changes
you move your King away and you promote
right very good now he is going to go
here because he is hoping when you move
the bishop he can put it on a short
diagonal now
what do you do now
we should reforge the problem as he
takes and you're not the first one
you're not the first one who suggests
that many people actually think of this
year put the bishop the flag but the
problem we see the Flex ant controls the
square so you gotta be careful yeah yes
well we should be seven it's same thing
yeah it goes back Murray you already got
the right idea
you got him away from the long long
diagonal right well it we have to be a
little bit more precise we can't just
move like say he moved here that didn't
work so you have to be precise yeah
where you move the bishop three correct
now what can he do now you're going to
promote right so he's going to go here
to stop that
but now the difference is well we got
him into the short diagonal and the
reason you wanted the King to be here
because you want him to control one of
the squares on that short diagonal so
now he doesn't have many squares well if
you put it back next to the king he goes
back so it's saying it's we're not
making progress you're two moves away to
move some way from winning this game yes
very good we say tak we takes we're done
yeah Queen versus Bishop it's a win so
he goes here only move only move and the
final touches
here you you keep on giving the vision
that's probably winning but nice finish
who can find a nice finish here
very good did you realize that this is
the nice finish not well if it takes the
bishop we take his bishop and these
squares are taken so you cannot do much
so and he cannot really keep the bishop
on this diagonal anymore
okay so we win this yes yeah yeah it's
prob we're here right yeah but then he
can move to ok then you want to bring
the bishop right yeah
yeah then you go here yeah it's winning
- yeah you can do that - but ok it's
just you can just go here and here this
is this is the way out
just do it ok so remember you first goal
is to try to move the bishop from the
long diagonal to the short diagonal and
the way you decide here you want your
king remember I asked you where do we
want to go with the king here because at
this point it might have been that clear
where we want the king to be but you
should know that when you have a pawn on
the seventh rank about to Queen and a
bishop is guarding it you kind of try to
move that Bishop away from the long
diagonal to the short diagonal now it's
white to play and win
think about it if fish fc7 I will take
ya have King and Bishop so you already
know what's the team here right to win
move the bishop from the long diagonal
to the short data but it's tricky
because if you had your King on a eight
this could have been let's say if the
King was here this could have been
similar to the previous game we would
just simply transfer try to transfer the
bishop to a7 and after that we would go
Bishop e8 we move away we want a queen
so he's on of this is a really short
diagonal and then just at this move you
would win but the problem is the
position I set it up the king is not
only eight the problem is king is on c8
there is only one way to win this
position
and it's similar to the other end game
we'll learn today
so this is a connection actually with
the other end games and this Bishop end
games
so just think about it and try to find
what should be our first goal here
yes here
well yeah you don't have to just go to
g1 anywhere on this diagonal then you
can go yeah well the question is how are
you going to reach a7 this is the
question if you reach to a7 you will win
this game so remember if we if we can
just if we just get his Bishop away from
the diagonal we will win the game but
the question is how to do that Julian
oh sorry he goes here yeah I know what
you're trying to do but it goes here
I know yeah you were trying to gain a
temple he was trying to gain a temple
attacking my bishop and getting 187 but
after Bishop d6 is not easy because if
it tries to do that then I go back and
it can't go here to get here because I
just take if I had put the bishop
anywhere else you could have
accomplished that deflection idea and
get the bishop to a seven
must be missing something
why not just take the vision and put it
on 84 well that's the first move but
it's not just going to wait until you
transfer the bishop there is going to
prevent that check here and here
don't rush don't rush here so that's the
defense he puts the King on a6 now he's
stopping you from going to a7 see that's
why if we had our King here the task
would have been much easier we would
have the yeah Bishop c5 correct
now he can move the King from here
because if he tries to attack it he
loses and we get the bishop here so it's
going to go Bishop g3
don't give up your bishop again this
time was okay but still it's a little
detail it's a little detail here that
makes a big difference in end games it's
like this one little detail makes a
difference we should be seven correct
correct
now if I don't do anything easy when
yeah the ship date the ship c7 you just
block it and win so I have to go here
only move because if you don't do
anything I will simply go pick up d8 he
will have to go here I'll go Bishop c7
and block and Quinn okay so here so try
to stop white from putting the bishop on
c7 this is what is trying to say is
going to try to go here now
check is correct and now it looks like
we reach almost the same position I set
it up for you it's almost the same
position but there is a detail there is
a difference here who can notice the
differentiation not you yes what is the
difference aha that's very important you
know that's that's very important
so it's bishop is on a different square
can we take advantage of that that the
bishop is on a different square then on
h2 bishop was on h2 by the way in
original position by doing this maneuver
you force this bishop to be on g3 or
some other square on that diagonal
excellent attacking your bishop he can
take so you win a temple okay so he can
take because you Quinn he has to go here
bishop f2 now see he cannot reach a six
in two moves that's the whole point you
gain a temple okay you gain important
temple here he can add this so these are
the details of the bishop ending game so
now he goes here now you already know
how to win this here move the bishop
from the long diagonal to the short
diagonal
is create continued
Bishop e5 yo just go h2 not g3 because
he takes so he goes here and now that's
it okay
that's how you win this game that's when
you have a pawn on the seven trunk and
same color Bishop is not only it's it's
normal its winning but you have to know
that you need to get his Bishop from the
long diagonal to the short diagonal okay
okay very good
let's not do a couple of routine games
okay now you're playing with the white
pieces here you're playing with the
white pieces it's a one of the most
important positions actually to know in
the rookie endgame you're white
okay okay the way it works if you look
at the position right this is a 1 right
so this pawn is the spawn cannot go this
way so he has to go this way so remember
so white to play and win is what okay
let's just think yeah let's just think
here who knows this position raise your
hand yeah what's the name of this you
know this one okay uh-huh
you know this position uh-huh yeah okay
yeah okay I've had actually this
position a couple of times so it's very
important okay so we have a lot of
players that are new to this you can cut
the same game so let's see so this
position is winning it's winning okay
but you have to know how to win this the
first thing you have to remember here
you have the kink now cut
if you let this king get on the same
file as your passport it's going to be a
draw so you don't you always make sure
you have the cut so King cannot cross
the D line here for example okay now the
first goal is for us to try to advance
this pawn how can we advance this pawn
because looks like he's attacking from
behind yeah oh now look the forest okay
Rock d4 is okay but you could play rock
d4 yeah but what else what else we can
do
yeah you could probably do that too but
normally you don't need to you know you
just keep the rope to cut the king
right now the rook in a job for the rook
is just to keep the king cut we're going
to be able to push the spawn with the
king and upon so how do we do that yes
yeah don't go to d5 you let the king in
okay you let the king in don't go to d5
okay so again don't go here because I
told you he's going to King is going to
get in front of the pawn will be a draw
so your king b5 now he's going to go
check you go to c6 now he goes here
attacking your pawn yes very good
now he's going to wait let's say correct
now he goes here
now when you reach this position there
is another important detail to do here
okay when you have this position you
want to give a check here with your rope
to move his kink
yeah just raise your hand it would be
good for you to learn her yeah see
everybody is raising their hand yeah so
try to do that too so now you want to
give a check here to move his King
further away from your pawn so you go
check okay now you cannot go to any of
the squares so he has to go here now you
need to continue with your main plan to
try to advance this pawn all the way
check
where do you go yes now he goes here
attacking the pawn yes see much better
very good if you raise your hand I ask
you if you just say moose okay now so we
reach this position and now by the way
it's a very important move now black
needs to play here because if he plays
the wrong move here you can just win
easily so he needs to play route b1 here
to stop your king from going to the B
file and actually stop rugby to move
let's say if he doesn't play that move
right let's say he moves the King you
simply go route B - you put your rook
here first so when you move the thing
you go here now he has no checks and now
you're ready to Quinn so he's going to
go here to d7 you go check he has to
take now you check and you wind rock
okay so he has to play the move rook b1
if he wants to put the better resistance
still losing but he has to do that now
and not we don't have our position I
don't think we use our position here so
in this position here now the final idea
here if you don't know this idea you're
not going to be able to win this game
okay so what do you do here remember
yes go ahead you forgot ok tink tink
yeah you know this one yeah
raise your hand if you know how to win
this position alright good so words I'm
glad we're doing these things this is
very important that you know very well
even if you maybe you think you know it
but it's still you have to know exactly
how to win this yeah you might be able
to that yeah yeah actually to go this
way yeah yeah yeah it could be but but
normally anyway you win this way this is
the way everybody wins
so yes
hmm
you you want to go here yeah you could
do that but normally the the e you can
in this position when you have the King
away you want to get your King out okay
but you cannot go right away because
he's going to check you now you check
and he's going to check you and you
can't really do anything and you can win
your pawn so what you want to do here
you have to move your rook to the fourth
rank so let's say place here Brooke
efore so he goes here and now now you
can move your king check
King d6 check king c5 and now you play
rock c4 and now after you exchange the
rooks see his king is too far away from
your pawn that's why earlier you want to
give the check to move his King further
away from the pump because otherwise can
catch it okay so that's how you win this
position okay so let's let me change
this so we have only that idea so now
you know how to win so let's see if you
can actually get to that position okay
that were you walk your king
yes King to a5 again now we have them
cut on a C file so if we have to make
sure always that he cannot cross okay so
now King a5 check King b6 rook PQ
now he plays King d8 King a 6v6 and
remember in this position you give a
check right with the rook from d1 now
check because we want to not check from
here because it's not going to do
anything he just goes back so we go
check to move them away from the pawn
and now you continue with your plan of
trying to push the pawn to the seventh
rank so how do we do that
doesn't matter see seven or seven yeah
check now I got this position and which
important move now black needs to play
if it doesn't play this move you win
easily rook a to right because let's say
if you place any move you go rook a one
you control the a file and it tries to
get closer you go here he goes here you
promote into a queen check
he takes check and you win the rock okay
so now let's say he plays rook a - now
you put the rook on the fourth rank okay
that's very important your rope needs to
be on the for the knight on a fifth rank
because if you go here you get under
attack okay yes no because if you go
here he's going to lock your king in
check here he keeps your King locked now
can really you have to go back and do it
the other way okay so that's why you
don't want to do that you just simply
bring the rope to the fourth rank not a
few Frank fort rank now he goes here
let's say he goes here King c7 check
check and now let's see he's not
checking because he knows at this point
probably if he checks
you just go to b5 and go look before so
he's going to go route B - and now what
is the winning move here well if you go
to c7 he still checks
now see we cannot go to before which we
really want to do he takes and if we
cannot go Kings if I because it takes
our pawn very good look d5 with the idea
of yes looked if a very good move
now it goes here and look b5 and after
the exchange then King cannot stop the
pond okay so this is the very famous
Lucina position okay so we went over
King upon any game the bishop endgame
and the rook endgame okay today so it's
very important to do more end games I
think all of you if you can practice
some more end games this will really
help